Speaker 1: Donald Trump completely face planted
and humiliated himself in a disastrous new
interview from yesterday with right wing radio
host Hugh Hewitt.
Let's look at a couple of moments here on
Hugh Hewitt's program.
Donald Trump tried to claim that it's very
common to send an alternate slate of electors
to claim, oh, give our state's electoral votes
to the guy who lost.
The truth is, it's not common.
But Trump says it as if he's telling the truth
because he lies every second.
Speaker 2: They are attempting, I think, to
indict people for plans to select alternative
electors on one side.
Have you received a target letter, Mr. President?
Speaker 3: No, I haven't at all.
And frankly, when you look at alternate slates
that were that's been done for decades and
decades, many, many years.
Speaker 1: Now that's a lie.
What has been done for decades and decades
is that.
You have people identified and the people
are aware.
Okay.
If Biden wins, you would be you would be a
Biden elector.
Other people are told if Trump wins, you would
be a Trump elector.
What is not done is that biden wins.
The biden electors are notified.
It's yal because biden won and then republicans
start calling random people who were not going
to be the trump slate of electors to say,
hey, what if we just show up anyway?
That it is not true?
That that is typical.
Speaker 3: Alternate slates are actually common.
I wasn't involved with alternate slates, but
I can tell you many people have been for many,
many years doing alternate slates.
In fact, your friend Tucker Carlson did a
story on it last night that would have you
standard way of, you know, working elections.
Speaker 1: They got completely untrue.
Completely untrue.
Donald Trump asked during this interview about
what if the DOJ indicts you?
And again, Donald Trump alludes to violence.
Take a listen to this.
This is incredible.
Speaker 2: You know the old saying, a prosecutor
can indict a ham sandwich if they want to.
I'm just asking if there is such a prosecutor
and they indict you.
Would that deter you from running for president
again?
Speaker 3: I don't think the people of the
United States would stand for it.
And as you know, if a thing like that happened,
I would have no prohibition against running.
You know that.
Speaker 2: I do.
And that's what I want people to understand.
That would not take you out of the arena.
Speaker 3: It would not.
But I think if it happened, I think you'd
have problems in this country, the likes of
which perhaps we've never seen before.
So I don't think the people of the United
States would stand for it.
Speaker 2: What kind of problems, Mr. President?
Speaker 3: I think they'd have big problems.
Big problems.
I just don't think that stand for it.
They will not they will not sit still and
stand for this ultimate of hoaxes.
Speaker 1: That is a threat.
That is a threat from the former president
to unleash his own supporters on the country.
That is what that is.
One other clip that we're going to take a
look at here.
Speaker 2: Do you feel like the Department
of Justice is trying to indict you, Mr. President?
Speaker 3: Well, there is no reason that they
can be, other than if they are just sick and
deranged, which is always possible, because
I did absolutely.
You see in the legal papers, absolutely nothing
wrong.
And there's no reason that they can do that.
And I'll tell you what I would have said.
There's no way they can raid a house either,
because, you know, it's Fourth Amendment stuff.
And what they did is.
Speaker 1: That they everything was signed
off on.
Everything was legal.
It was not an illegal search and seizure.
Speaker 3: Terrible.
And I don't think the people are going to
stand for it.
If you noticed, the poll numbers are the highest
they've ever been.
The people are not going to stand for this
stuff.
They've left.
Speaker 1: So then he goes back into that
entire entire thing.
And then lastly, asked about the classified
documents, Trump claims he declassified declassified
everything he took to Mar a Lago, except his
lawyers are not making that argument in court
because it's an absurd argument.
Speaker 2: Mr. Patel said he witnessed you
giving verbal orders to declassify the papers
that end up at Mar a Lago.
Do you remember making those orders?
Speaker 3: That's correct.
And not only that, I think it was other people
also were there.
But I have the absolute right to declassify.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: And of course, as we've said before,
the classification status of these documents
is not relevant to all of the crimes Trump
is being investigated for.
You can't just look at a whole bunch of documents
and say, declassify.
Even William Barr admitted that.
But the big highlight here, or lowlight, is
Trump threatening to unleash his followers
on the country.
That was a signal.
You're not going to stand for it.
You're going to go crazy in the streets if
they indict me.
Very dangerous stuff.